Hello everyone and welcome to three of
you. Today Bible Q&A. My name is Ian
Vanderval. I'm going to be hosting your
program today. And I'm just so excited
because we do so many different programs
here. Uh me being one of the producers,
I get to get involved with all the
different uh programming that we do. And
this one right here, I have to admit, is
one of my favorites because we get to
answer your questions. And I know I have
many questions about the Bible. Even
those who are sitting here have
questions of the Bible. but we dive into
God's word and that's where we get our
answers from is strictly from the word
of God. So I want to thank you for
joining us today and that we have the
opportunity to answer your questions. So
what if you are new and maybe this is
the first time you're coming across this
program I want to tell you how you can
uh turn in your questions. So you can
ask them if you are on social media
specifically on Instagram, you can go to
3ABN_official
and you can send us a direct message
through Instagram and send us your
question there. So that's 3ABN_official.
Uh if you want, you could send in your
your texts to us and and send in your
questions to 6182283975.
Again, that is 618-228-3975.
And lastly and uh not least, you can
always send in an email to us which is
bible qa3abn.tv.
Again, I want to say that uh one more
time for those who are listening on
radio bibleqa3abn.tv.
Now, I want to also introduce you to the
gentlemen who are going to be answering
your questions today. I know that
they've been in prayer. I know that
they've been in study to be able to
answer your questions and to do them and
to be led by the Holy Spirit. So, right
across the table from me is Derell
Thomas. Derell,
>> uh, thank you for having me and, uh,
it's a blessing to be on here again to
find answers in God's word.
>> Amen. Amen. And we also have Pastor John
Dindsey who's joining us today. Welcome,
sir.
>> Thank you so much. It's a blessing to be
here. And yes, it is true. A lot of
prayer is put into uh finding answers in
God's word.
>> Amen. Amen. And I know this is kind of
new for me. Usually, I'm on on the other
side answering the questions. So, I'm
actually going to enjoy being to ask you
guys the questions today and to sit here
and learn. So, I'm excited about that.
But before we go any further, we don't
want to uh open up SC God's word and
speak about spiritual things without
inviting the Holy Spirit to be with us
and also to be with you at home because
we want to make sure that you are being
led and guided by the Holy Spirit as
well. So, Pastor Dingji, would you mind
uh praying for us?
>> Yes.
>> Thank you. Our loving and precious
heavenly father, we thank you so much
for all that you do for each and every
one of us. And even today, Lord, you are
speaking to your children in one way or
another. And we [music] pray that this
will be one more way to speak to your
children. We pray for the blessing of
your Holy Spirit for us, that you will
speak through us, and that you also will
bless your children to hear and
understand. We thank you so much for the
holy scriptures that you have provided
for us to be a light for our path and to
help us understand [music]
that you are a wonderful savior and that
you have a plan to rescue each and every
one of us. Help us to rejoice and be
glad in your plan of salvation [music]
and to have that blessed hope in our
hearts. We ask you in the holy and
blessed name of Jesus. Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you, Pastor Denzy.
>> All right, so we're gonna kick it right
off now. We're going to go to our first
question. Derell, I'm going to come
across to the table and and give you
your first question. So, this comes from
Ted from Georgia and he sends in the
text and he asks, "If God's moral law is
unchanging, why did the Old Testament
permit practices like slavery and
capital punishment for certain offenses
while the New Testament seems to
overturn or ignore them?"
>> Uh, well, thank you, Ted, for your
question. And it's true that when we
hear terms like slavery and capital
punishment, it can kind of uh prick our
our Christian uh senses a bit, they
become heightened because we struggle to
uh reconcile uh what we see in Exodus
chapter 21 and you know what Christ
ordained in the New Testament. But let's
unpack the principles that are found in
Exodus 21 because we want to come to the
conclusion that God does not contradict
himself and in fact he does not
contradict what he explains as his
character in Exodus 34 6 to7 which says
the Lord said that he is the Lord the
Lord God merciful and gracious
long-suffering and abounding in goodness
and truth keeping mercy for thousands
forgiving iniquity and transgression and
sin
by no means clearing the guilty. And so
when the regulations about servants u
were put in place in the book of Exodus
chapter 21, slavery was already a
widespread practice uh within many of
the near eastern um cultures of that
time. And so this was not God telling
them to take slaves. This was God
recognizing that the practice was
already in play amongst his people. And
because of their unwillingness to
change, he put guidelines in place for
how they were to treat their servants.
So in many cases particularly when we're
talking about uh ser servants who would
be uh their fellow Hebrews uh servitude
functioned as debt repayment or economic
relief and with and there were
provisions that were put in place legal
uh protections as well that were put in
place because you uh in the passage it
says after six years of service uh the
servant was to be released if they
wanted to be released but the choice was
to be the servants and not the masters.
They could not be held against their
will. And likewise, the master was to
take care of them and treat them fairly.
So regarding capital punishment, there
was a specific guideline connected to
slavery in Exodus 21 20- 21, which says,
"If a man beats his male or female
servant with a rod, so that he dies
under his hand, he shall surely be
punished. Notwithstanding, if he remains
alive a day or two, he shall not be
punished, for he is his property. So
here again, God did not mandate that
servants should be beaten or killed. Out
of wisdom, he recognized that among the
children of Israel, there would be some
who would do such things, such heinous
things, and that he and then he placed
guidelines to limit their practices. So
if the master's beating resulted in
immediate death, he was to be punished
as a murderer. The law distinguished
between intentional killing and
unintended. We see things like that
today with uh murder versus
manslaughter, but both are not God's
will. So if the servant survived a day
or two, the passage says it was
understood that there was not pre that
it was not premeditated intent. So there
is much nuance here because we get into
well what was the motive uh in the heart
of the master but what we know for sure
is that this guideline was put in place
because of the hardness of the hearts of
the children of Israel. You see they
refused to abide by God's will and
therefore in order to maintain the
covenant that he had established with
them he put laws in place to manage
their wewardness. Jesus himself
explained this principle in Matthew
chapter 19 when speaking of divorce. He
said that Moses because of the hardness
of your hearts permitted you to divorce.
But from the beginning it was not so.
Jesus was establishing that certain
civil laws and penalties written in
places like Exodus Exodus 21 were not
expressions of God's original ideal but
rather his way of dealing with already
existing matters in a fallen society in
a way that would still leave room for
repentance um where it's possible.
>> Amen. Amen. And I love how you said
right in the beginning that the Bible
does not contradict.
>> And so many times when we're reading
God's word, we think we come across
something that's contradicting itself,
but when we study more and you know, if
you ask questions like this, it helps us
to clarify those things. So, thank you
so much. I appreciate that.
>> Sure.
>> Uh, Pastor Denzy, so your first question
here comes from Anthony in Ohio. He
sends in this text and he asks, "What
happened to Joseph, the father of Jesus?
Why isn't he mentioned in the rest of
the gospel? Did he die or did he divorce
his wife Mary?
Thank you so much. That is a very good
question. And so we need to dive into
God's word to find the answer. You know,
it's interesting because he is not
mentioned. And there are many things in
the Bible that, you know, we look at and
we say, well, why isn't this talked
about or that talked about? And we can
see firsthand that it uh he did not have
a prominent role
uh to be mentioned. But let's go ahead
and look at some places where Joseph is
mentioned. First, we go to Matthew
chapter 2. And I'm going to read verse
13. And it says, "And when they were
departed, behold, the angel of the Lord
appearth to Joseph in a dream, saying,
Arise and take the young child and his
mother and flee into Egypt, and be thou
there until I bring thee word, for Herod
will seek the young child to destroy
him." So, this is after the birth. We we
remember that in Matthew chapter 1 uh
the angel does talk to Joseph telling
him don't don't uh put away Mary you
know stay stay with her and the young
child the child that is going to be born
is of the Holy Spirit but here in verse
uh Matthew 21:19 it says but when Herod
was dead behold an angel of the Lord
appearth in a dream to Joseph in Egypt
saying arise take the young child and
his mother and go into the land of
Israel for they are dead which sought
the young child's life. And he arose and
took the young child and his mother and
came into the land of Israel. But when
he heard of Archelaus that Archelaus did
reign in Judea, and in the room of his
father Herod, he was afraid to go
thither. Notwithstanding, being warned
of God in a dream, he turned aside into
the parts of Galilee. All of these
verses tell us that Joseph was a
righteous man, one that served the Lord
and the Lord spoke to him in different
times, spoke to him in a dream and he
understood that it was the Lord talking
to him. So the idea of him divorcing
Mary, it seems something that should not
even be be considered because uh Mary
the mother of Jesus, faithful to the
Lord, Joseph, a righteous man, the idea
of divorce does not fit into the picture
as to why he is not mentioned. Let's go
now into
uh let's see Luke chapter 2. Luke
chapter 2 uh beginning in verse 42. And
when he was 12 years old, they went up
to Jerusalem after the custom of the
feast. Now Jesus is 12 years old and
Joseph is mentioned. I'm going to go
ahead and uh go to verse 43. And when
they had fulfilled the days as they
returned, the child Jesus tried behind
in Jerusalem and Joseph and his mother
knew not of it. So we see at 12 years
old, Jesus being 12 years old, Joseph is
still mentioned. So he's still around.
But there comes a time when Joseph is
not mentioned and it appears not to be
around. But in John 6:42, we are not
sure if Joseph is still alive. But
notice the wording here. And they said,
"Is not this Jesus the son of Joseph
whose father and mother we know? Who how
is it that he saith, I came down from
heaven?" So about 30 years old, Joseph
was still known and that he was the
father of Jesus. So after this, Joseph
Joseph is not mentioned. But why? He did
not play a prominent role. But it is
believed that he passed away. Why do we
think he passed away? There's a scene
now that Jesus is dying on the cross.
And in the book of John, we have a verse
that helps us understand Joseph is not
around. Joseph is gone. Joseph more than
likely passed away. I think we it's a
safe conclusion to say Joseph passed
away. Why? Notice uh we go to John
chapter 19.
And so here
in verse 26 and 27, when Jesus therefore
saw his mother and the disciples
standing by whom he loved, he saith unto
his mother,"Woman, behold thy son,"
talking about John. Then saith he to the
disciples, to the disciple John, "Behold
thy mother." And from that hour that
disciple took her unto his own home.
Why? to his own home. She needed some
help. She needed somebody to be with
her. And Joseph was not around.
Obviously, he's not around because why
is Jesus saying why does why does it say
that from that day John took her to his
own home? So, we conclude here safe to
conclude that Joseph had passed away and
now his mother needed somewhere to have
shelter. And so why is Joseph not
mentioned in other places? I mean Jesus
appeared to be 30 and Joseph appeared to
still be around. He did not play a
prominent role. The focus is Jesus. The
focus is his mission. The focus is the
miracles. The focus is that he is the
way, the truth, and the life. And so
this is uh these are reasons why Joseph
is not mentioned.
>> Amen. Amen. You know, I wondered the
same thing for a while is you know why
why does it seem like Joseph kind of
gets left off? So, I'm really glad you
answered it that way. That was a real
blessing. Thank you. Um, all right,
Derell, we're going to come back to you.
This is coming from Jennifer in South
Carolina. She sends this text and she
says, "Does the Bible talk about giants
walking the earth? If so, who or what
are they talking about?" Thank you,
Jennifer, for your question. And the
Bible does indeed talk about giants
walking the earth both before and after
the flood. We find the first mention of
giants walking the earth in the book of
Genesis chapter 6 where Moses said in
verse one. Now it came to pass when men
began to multiply on the face of the
earth and daughters were born to them
that the sons of God saw the daughters
of men that they were beautiful and they
took wives for themselves of all who of
whom they chose. And the Lord said, "My
Spirit shall not strive with man
forever, for he is indeed flesh, yet his
days shall be 120 years." And there were
giants on the earth in those days. And
also afterward, when the sons of God
came into the daughters of men, and they
bore children to them, those were the
were um were the mighty men who were of
old, men of renown. So, the first
chapters of Genesis help guide us in
understanding who or what these giants
were. You see, some people postulate
that these giants were a halfh human,
half angel uh race of supernatural
beings. But there's no mention in
Genesis chapters 1 to5 of angels
marrying or uh producing offspring
offspring with human beings. What is
mentioned is that from out of Adam and
Eve were born three notable sons. Cain,
Abel, who was murdered by Cain, and then
Seth. Now, at this time, um, as time
went on in the Bible, uh, the Bible
depicts that Cain and his descendants,
uh, they decided to go further and
further into sin and rebellion. And then
Seth and his descendants were, uh,
depicted as remaining loyal to God. And
as the Bible says uh in verse uh 26 I
believe of Genesis chapter 4 it says and
as for Seth to him also a son was born
and he named him Enosh then man began to
call on the name of the Lord. So this
was the trait shared by many of Seth
Seth's descendants including Enoch who
was translated without seeing death and
Noah who found grace in the sight of the
Lord and was preserved on the ark. Uh so
all of these uh descendants of Seth had
this characteristic and scripture
presents two contrasting lines that
existed at the beginning of time. We
have this rebellious rebellious line of
Cain and then we have this loyal line of
Seth. Scripture even calls Adam the son
of God in his original state of
obedience. And those who followed his
example of repentance and obedience to
God likewise became the sons of God.
That's the line of Seth. And spiritually
speaking, this is the same uh this is
the case with with each and every one of
us who choose to make peace with God as
well. The Bible says, "Blessed are the
peacemakers, for they shall be called
the sons of God." Matthew 5:9. So those
who were loyal and made peace with God
can reasonably reasonably be understood
as the sons of God in Genesis chapter 6.
Unfortunately, as time went on, some of
them like the judge Samson found
themselves desiring those who were not
spiritually like them. In other words,
those who were once loyal to God decided
to have children with the rebellious
children of Cain. But this does not mean
that all of the giants of that time were
necessarily the result of those
intermarages between believers and
unbelievers. Scripture simply describes
them as mighty men who lived in a
culture that grew increasingly violent
and corrupt. The word used to describe
the giants is Nephilim. The exact exact
meaning of Nephilim is often debated,
but the Bible describes them as mighty
men of renown living before the flood.
Nonetheless, the Bible does speak of
giants existing after the flood as well.
The spies who brought an evil report
after returning from the Canaan land
said in Numbers 13:33, "There were there
we saw the giants Nephilim. The
descendants of Anch came from the giants
and we were like grass grasshoppers in
our sight and so we were in their sight.
So in the Canaan land there were
numerous tribes of people considered to
be giants. Um and then even later uh in
in the years that passed we see Goliath
and others from different uh pagan
nations having giant stature. The key is
that the giants who are explicitly
mentioned in scripture appear in
opposition to God and his covenant
people consistently. None are described
as faithful worshippers of the Lord. So
to answer your question of who or what
these giants were about, the answer is
that these were giant human beings,
powerful and influential, who are
consistently portrayed as opposing God
rather than honoring him.
>> Amen. Amen. That was I don't know how
you fit that all in there, but praise
God.
>> Praise [laughter] the Lord.
>> Amen.
>> Praise the Lord.
>> So, all right, Pastor Denzy, we're going
to go to uh your next question, and that
is in Job 14:22.
Who does his refer to the dead or the
sons? And this is from Audra in Georgia
and she texted this question. Thank you
Audra. I gather from the way you are
expressing your question that you have
some understanding as to what happens
when a person dies and this is why your
question has come up. And this is a very
interesting passage of scripture I have
to say and it does seem to have an
element of wow this seems to contradict
other scriptures. So there must be an
explanation because there is no
contradiction in the holy scriptures. Uh
let's go ahead and read uh Job 14 21 and
22. It says his sons come to honor. He's
talking about a dead person. His sons
come to honor, and he knoweth it not,
and they are brought low, but he
perceiveth it not of them. But his flesh
upon him shall have pain, and his soul
within him shall mourn. That's the King
James version. So, what is going on
here? Who is this he or uh as you said,
who is the his? The his are his uh it
says his flesh. It's talking about the
dead person, not the person's alive. But
there are some possibilities here. But
before I go there, I want to read the
New King James Version. And it says,
"His sons come to honor. He does not
know it. They are brought low, and he
does not perceive it.
But his flesh will be in pain over it,
and his soul will mourn over it." Now
notice here that it is talking about a
dead person and it's not um identifying
if the person is good or bad. Basically
it's really everyone that dies has this
experience. But we have to say wait a
minute how can his flesh have pain once
he is dead. So we understand that is not
a possibility. You cannot have pain
after you die. And what about this part
about mourning? That you cannot mourn
after you are dead. It's an
impossibility. Let's go ahead and read
Ecclesiastes chapter 9 verse 5 and 6.
For the living know that they will die,
but the dead know nothing and they have
no more reward for the memory of them is
forgotten. So the idea of the dead
perceiving feeling pain is not possible.
Notice verse six. Also their love, their
hatred and their envy have now perished.
Never more will they have a share in
anything done under the sun, including
pain, including feeling hot or cold. And
good news for those of you that do not
know about the state of the dead. uh if
somebody tells you when I die I'm going
to come back to you as a ghost and no
they cannot come back they are dead and
they are in the grave until the
resurrection the resurrection of the
righteous or the resurrection of
damnation and we'll talk about that in a
moment if we have time so they are they
are not capable of feeling pain so one
possibility is that the person alive is
considering I'm going to be dead I'm not
going to perceive my son's doing well or
my son's doing uh badly. Uh so in flesh
while the person is alive, you feel pain
over that. I can't help them. I won't
know anything. Uh and you can mourn over
that experience. So this is one
possibility. So you can mourn while
you're alive because you cannot mourn
after you are dead. Now, interestingly
enough, there are some that consider
this a poetic description and
personification of someone that has
passed away. Uh, actually I have uh
there's an individual by the name of
Adam Clarkson commentary and he quot
he's quoting somebody else. He says,
"Mr. Stock translates translates thus
both the spirit and the letter. But over
him his flesh shall grieve and over his
breath shall mourn. In the daring spirit
of oriental poetry, says he, the flesh
or body and the breath are made
conscious beings, the former lamenting
its putrification in the grave, the
latter mourning over the moldering clay
which once it uh enlivened. So this is
another possibility because the Bible
does do that. Sometimes it gives
personification to something that does
not really have life at all. If you
want, you can read in Judges chapter
nine and there's a parable of the trees
talking. It says that one tree said to
another tree, "We need to find the king.
[laughter]
Let's find the king." And so they're
talking, the trees are talking. Do trees
talk? No, they don't. So the Bible
sometimes gives personification to
things that are not really alive. So but
let's go ahead and go to Job chapter 14.
In Job chapter 14, actually Job chapter
4, it says, "How much verse 19, 20, and
21, how much does how much more those
who dwell in houses of clay, we dwell in
houses of clay, whose foundation is in
the dust, who are crushed before a moth,
they are broken in pieces from morning
till evening. and they perish forever
with no one regarding. Does not their
own excellence go away? They die even
without wisdom. So the dead know
nothing, experience nothing. They're not
suffering. And so I now go to the
resurrection. John 5:28 and 29. Marvel
not at this, for the hour is coming in
the which all that are in the grave
shall hear his voice.
Verse 29. and they shall come forth,
they that have done good unto the
resurrection of life, and they that have
done evil unto the resurrection of
damnation. So while people are in the
grave, they're not suffering, they're
not hearing, they're not listening, they
have no participation in anything done
under the sun, including pain or any
type of suffering. They are in the grave
until the resurrection of the righteous
or the resurrection of damnation. I hope
this helps.
>> Amen. Amen. I think we need to do a
whole Bible Q&A on that question, I
think. All right. So, uh, Derell, I'm
coming to you. This is from Michaela in
Jamaica. She sends in this email and
asks, "Why do we no longer celebrate
Pentecost?"
>> U, Michaela, that's a a great question.
Uh, and it actually finds its answer in
what Christ fulfilled when he when and
after he came to the world. uh and the
most direct answer I can give to you is
that the feast of Pentecost as first
described in the Old Testament found its
true fulfillment in the book of Acts
chapter 2. With that said, I don't want
it to be u misconstrued that um
Pentecost has nothing to do with our
present experience as Christians. On the
contrary, that day empowered the church
to move forward with spirit-led power
and zeal. In fact, without that day, the
church would not be in existence today.
The Bible says in John 15:26, "But when
the helper comes whom I shall send to
you from the father, the spirit of truth
who proceeds from the father, he will
testify of me," said Jesus. However, uh
then John 16:13 it says, "However, when
he, the Spirit of truth, has come, he
will guide you into all truth, for he
will not speak on his own authority, but
whatever he hears, he will speak and he
will tell you things to come." So, what
we know about what happened when the
spirit was poured out on the day of
Pentecost is that um it was a gift that
keeps on giving. The benefits uh of the
day of Pentecost have expanded and
increased since that day. But when we
talk about observing Pentecost, we must
ask the question, what exactly would we
would we be observing? We would be
observing a sec uh would we be observing
a sacrificial ceremony um as they did in
the Old Testament? Um or um would we be
observing something that Christ had
already fulfilled? Um, recall that the
Old Testament spoke not just of the
benefits of the following feast days,
Passover, unleaven bread, first fruits,
Pentecost, but it also pointed to future
fulfillments of other feast days after
that day in the book of Acts. Future
feasts at that time included the feast
of trumpets, the day of atonement, and
finally the feast of tabernacles. So all
of these feasts were to find their true
fulfillment in Christ and through his
church. Once fulfilled, we then move
from celebrating the feast to
celebrating the benefits of the
fulfillment of that feast. Just think of
how wonderful it is to know that the
spirit of God is freely available to all
who ask God in sincerity. That he that
uh he the spirit of God caused 3,000
souls to be baptized in one day. and to
know that that's the same spirit that is
available to us through Pentecost.
Rather than celebrating the day of
Pentecost each year as a yearly one-time
festival, we have the great priv
privilege of celebrating daily daily
being re um renewed by the very same
spirit of God who descended upon the
disciples in the upper room. And if we
live daily with that knowledge, we don't
have to deprive ourselves from observing
um feast days such as um Pentecost,
knowing that um I shouldn't say we we
don't have to deprive ourselves, but we
don't have to continue uh observing
these feast days such as Pentecost,
knowing that for the majority of the
time that that particular feast was
being observed in an uh it involved um
sacrifice and and offering, drink
offerings, grain offerings, sin
offerings. So what happened in Acts
chapter 2 uh was a very unique
experience. It was it was that
fulfilling ultimate experience and uh
with the apostle Paul we can look now
toward Christ who fulfilled the
ceremonial feast of Pentecost by
bringing the pre prerequisite of unity
among his disciples and then sending his
spirit to earth like fire. And that
tells us something special. Whenever we
are unified and spiritfilled, we are
living in the reality that Pentecost
made possible. And that is how we
celebrate Pentecost even until Jesus
returns. And so we don't have to observe
feast days as they did back then because
that would involve many things like
sacrifices and offerings. But what we
can look to is Jesus who is working
through those feasts and fulfilling what
those feasts actually meant.
>> Amen. Amen. What a what a blessing that
answer was. I'm I'm taking notes from
from all these questions and it's kind
of amazing. One, you know, I said
earlier in the program, one of the
things I love about this program is just
how it's all Bible Q&A questions. It's
just it's all Bible and we've gone
through from the Old Testament, New
Testament, talked about the state of the
dead, giants, in this case, feast days.
We're just kind of packing everything
into it. So, if uh if you have a
question that maybe something maybe one
of these questions kind of, you know,
jogged you to, hey, I've been wondering
about this and made you think of
something else or maybe you have just
something completely different. Let me
remind you how you could send in your
questions. So, if you're on social
media, if you have an Instagram account,
you can send us a direct message at
3abn_official.
If you'd like to text them in, you can
send them to 618-2283975.
And lastly, you can send them in through
an email to us here at 3ABN at bible
qa3abn.tv.
So, we have so much more that we still
have to pack into this hour. So many
different questions. I want to make sure
that we have enough time to get to them
all. So, Pastor Denzy, I'm going to come
to you next. And this question comes
from Mike in Michigan. He actually
emails this question. And he says, "In
Luke 8, why did Jesus grant the demons
request to enter the pigs? It seems like
an act of mercy toward them. Yet, Satan
does not show mercy to humanity whether
we are children of God or not.
Thank you so much. That's a a very
thoughtful question, Mike. And I uh I
want to say that it's true. The devil
does not show any mercy to anybody under
any circumstances. And that's a
difference between uh one of the
differences between him and God. And so
God is merciful and he is just. What is
happening here is very interesting.
There are a lot of lessons in here in
Luke chapter 8 about the uh men uh
demonpossessed. And yes, it's going to
be interesting. Uh let me see if I can
share some things really quick here. So
Jesus uh goes to the country of the
gatherings and when they step out of uh
onto the land uh here's a
demon-possessed man coming as if to tear
them apart. I like the way it's in the
desire ages. It says when the disciples
see that, they run for their lives.
But Jesus and they they're running for
their lives and it seems as if they're
like, "Well, where's Jesus? Why is he
running with us?" And they look back and
Jesus is right where he was. And the he
just puts his hand out and the demons
can come no closer.
And so now I pick up I need to pick this
up in verse 31 because of time. Um
actually let me go in verse 29. For he
had commanded the unclean spirit to come
out of the man for it had often seized
him and he was kept under guard bound
with chains and shackles and he broke
the bonds and was driven by the demon
into the wilderness. Jesus asked him
saying what is your name? and he said
legion because many many um and you know
when you talk about legion you're
talking about between 4,000 and 6,000 as
far as the Roman soldiers is concerned
but but many demons had entered him and
they begged him that he would not
command them to go into the abyss and so
they're begging this is a beg now a herd
of many swine was feeding there on the
mountain so they begged him that he
would permit permit them to enter them
and he permitted them. One of the
lessons we see here is the devil cannot
uh possess even animals. They cannot
possess people without the people giving
authority and that's another topic. Uh
you can send in a question we'll talk
about that. Uh the devil the devils
cannot even go into animals without
receiving permission. And now it says um
then
and he permitted them. says, uh, "Then
the demons went out of the man, entered
into the swine, and the herd ran
violently down the steep place into the
lake and drowned."
Now, here's a key. Now, why did Jesus
allow this? It seems like he showed
mercy. Jesus knew what would happen. And
uh the devil, it seems like he wanted to
prevent Jesus from preaching the gospel
in that region because of what happens
next in the story.
But let's go ahead and uh go to verse
34. But when those who fed them saw what
had happened, they fled and told it to
the city and in the country. Then they
went out to see what had happened and
came to Jesus and found the man from
whom the demons had departed sitting at
the feet of Jesus, clothed and in his
right mind, and they were afraid. They
also who had seen it told them, "By what
means he who had been demonpossessed was
healed." Then the whole multitude of the
surrounding regions of the gatherings
asked him to depart from them for they
were seized with great fear and he got
into the boat and returned. It seems
like the devil got a victory. Oh, Jesus
could not preach the gospel. They told
him to leave. But
the demon-possessed man asked, "Can I go
with you, Jesus?" And Jesus said, "No,
you need to stay here." The man had a
mission. He had to continue preaching
the gospel. So he could tell us, I was
healed by Jesus. He was a living
testimony of the power of God. So what
happens next? And so it says here in
verse 39, is it 39? No, verse 40. It
says, "So it was when Jesus returned
that the multitude welcomed him for they
were all waiting for him." Praise the
Lord. That man that was demonpossessed
spread the good news about Jesus. So
when Jesus returned there, they welcomed
him because the testimony of this man.
Now why did Jesus allow the demons to go
into the swine is because these people
who are Jews, they were not supposed to
be dealing with swine and eating them
and selling them. So Jesus was also
trying to teach them a lesson. So it
seems like mercy, but Jesus had a
purpose for doing this.
>> Amen. And I love how you said we, you
know, he became a living testament of
the power of God.
>> Amen.
>> I love that. Amen. Uh, all right,
Derell. So, we have a question for you.
This comes from, uh, Missy in Tennessee.
She texted this question. She asks,
"Where was Jesus crucified? I've heard
it was on the Mount of Olives in the
direct view of the holy place. If so, is
that the same place as Goltha?"
>> Thank you, Missy, for your question, and
there's actually a clear answer that's
found in scripture. We begin in Matthew
chap 27 uh 33-35. It says, "And when
they had come to a place called Golgtha,
that is to say place of a skull." And
skip to verse 35, "Then they crucified
him and divided his garments." Then in
Mark 15, starting in verse 22, it says,
"And they brought him to the place
Golgtha, which is translated place of a
skull." and 20 verse 24. And when they
crucified him, they divided his
garments. Luke 23:33,
"And when they had come to the place
called Calvary, there they crucified him
and the criminals, one on the right hand
and the other on the left." Then in John
chapter 19 vers starting in verse 17 it
says and he bearing his cross went out
to a place called the place of a skull
which is called in Hebrew Golgtha where
they crucified him and two others with
him one on the either side and Jesus in
the center. So, and I know that there
are a number of different theories on
where Christ was crucified because we
know that the temple veil was torn in
two and some believe that it was seen
visibly from the cross. And then there
are theories that the sacrificial lamb
that was supposed to be sacrificed at
that hour ran away free and the priest
dropped the knife. But all of these are
not in the scriptures themselves.
rather they are based on either
traditions or teachings that came after
the text wasn't originally written. The
answer itself is is that Jesus was
crucified upon what was um was called
Mount Calvary or Golgtha which is
translated to mean the place of a skull.
This place is distinct and different
from the Mount of Olives. Calvary was
located outside of the walls of the city
of Jerusalem according to Hebrews
chapter 13:12 which says, "Therefore
Jesus also that he might sanctify the
people with his own blood suffered
outside the gate." And then the Mount of
Olives is located on the east of
Jerusalem. For in Zechariah 14:4 it
says, "The Mount of Olives faces
Jerusalem on the east."
So at no point does the Bible mention
the Mount of Olives as either the same
place as Golgtha or even an alternate
potential location for the crucifixion.
Likewise, there is no mention of the
crucifixion being in direct view of the
holy place of the temple. But that does
not mean that the mount of olives is not
a valid place in connection with what
happened on Mount Calvary. You see in
the garden of Gethsemane where Jesus as
it were sweat great drops of blood and
prayed to his father three times
pleading with him to take away this cup
of suffering
uh this was done on the Mount of Olives.
And then as we look to the future we
know that at after the thousand-year
period and that's another study after
the thousand-year period Jesus will set
down uh set foot on the Mount of Olives
and split it in two. But none of these
uh the past events or or future events
eliminate the fact that uh the
crucifixion location was most certainly
according to scripture Mount Calvary on
Goltha the place of a skull.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you. And what a what a
savior that we have that's even willing
to go through that for us. So amen. Uh
Pastor Denzy, so your question comes
from Esther. uh she emailed this
question and she says did God take a
risk in sending Jesus to earth and did
Jesus risk anything by coming?
>> Wow. Uh really to consider this question
is something
uh impacting I would say and
was there any risk? Uh yes absolutely uh
100% there was a risk because there's a
great controversy between good and evil
and in this controversy between good and
evil
um
evil is saying God is not just God is
not fair uh asking
human beings to keep the law and you
know all these things are in play
and God's character is also at risk.
here
and so was was there a risk you know
let's consider
that Satan was right if Jesus failed in
the mission there was a risk now because
the Bible says when I say failed if
Jesus because the Bible says that Jesus
was tempted in all points like as we are
yet without sin but what if Jesus did
sin even by a thought if he sinned then
for us as human beings
We would be the slaves of the devil
without any restraint. God restrains the
devil from doing to us things that he
would love to do. Uh you that are
listening to me, he would love to
destroy you right now. Boom. Uh or
torment you, torture you until you can
take no more and kill yourself. But God
does not allow this. And so there's a
risk of God being found that oh no, you
were wrong and the devil was right.
There was a risk. And so what about
Jesus? Did Jesus risk anything in coming
to earth? Jesus being part of the deity,
part of the godhead and taking upon
himself human form. If he sinned, then
he would fall under the condemnation of
the law and it would apply to him that
the wages of sin is death. It's almost
horrible to think about. But why did the
devil go and tempt Jesus? Because the
devil knew that Jesus there was a
possibility that Jesus would fall into
sin. Why waste your time? Oh, he's the
son of God. He's not going to fail. He's
not going to fall into temptation.
Uh but it says tempted. What does that
mean? That means there's a challenge and
you have to make a choice. Uh let's go
ahead and go to Matthew chapter 4
beginning in verse one. Then Jesus was
Jesus was led by the spirit into the
wilderness to be tempted by the devil.
And when he had fasted 40 days and 40
nights, afterward he was hungry. Now
when the tempter came to him, he said,
"If you are the son of God, command that
these stones become bread." But he
answered and said, "It is written, man
shall not live by bread alone, but by
every word that proceeds from the mouth
of God." If you continue reading, you
will see that Jesus answered with the
word of God. And he's giving us an
example. But the devil went to tempt
Jesus because he knew there was a
possibility he would fall into sin. And
from the moment that Jesus could be
tempted until the moment that Jesus
could not be tempted, that is when he's
on the cross and he says it is finished
and he dies, that's when he could not be
tempted anymore. Uh the devil was on his
tracks. temptation after temptation, uh,
temptation after temptation. Because if
Jesus sinned once,
we would all be in a horrible, horrible
situation. As bad as it is now, it would
be worse because the devil would be in
control and we would be slaves. Praise
God that Jesus was victorious, was
tempted in all points like as we are,
and did not sin, became our perfect
sacrifice.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you, Pastor Denzy, for
that. Uh, Derell. So, this is a little
bit of a long question, so I'm just
going to get right to it. This is from
Aaliyah. She sends this email and says,
"My roommate and I were discussing the
gift of tongues. She believes that the
unknown tongue mentioned in 1
Corinthians 14 is a private heavenly
language directed to God and that even
if it sounds like gibberish, the Holy
Spirit gives it meaning. From my
understanding of scripture, tongues
refers to actual human languages. Can
you explain whether biblical tongues are
known language languages or
unintelligible speech and shed more
light on 1 Corinthians 14:es 1-2 in this
context?
>> Thank you Aaliyah for this uh question
and I pray that the answer is a blessing
to your roommate. Uh let's begin in Acts
chapter 2:3 where it says, "Then there
appeared to them divided tongues as of
fire and one set upon each of them and
they were all filled with the Holy
Spirit and began to speak with other
tongues as the Spirit gave them
utterance." Notice that the word tongues
is plural. What does this mean? The
tongues spoken on the day of Pentecost
were multiple distinct languages.
Why is this significant? Well, because
the modern definition of tongues often
assumes an unknown language. Yet on the
day of Pentecost, the language may have
been unknown to the speaker, but it was
not unknown to the hearers. How do we
know this? Acts 2:es 5-6 says, "There
were dwelling in Jerusalem Jews, devout
men from every nation under heaven. And
when this sound occurred, the multitude
came together and were were confused
because everyone heard them speak in his
own language. So we see how the gift of
tongues is connected to nonhuman
languages. As verse 11 says, we hear
them speaking in our own tongues the
wonderful works of God. Now the Bible is
clear that the gift of tongues was not
limited to the events of Pentecost. 1
Corinthians 12:10 speaks on spiritual
gifts saying to another diverse kinds of
tongues are given and to another the the
interpretation of tongues. Today we see
spirit-led interpreters across the world
translating sermons and studies. Pastor
Denzy is is one of them translating uh
sermons and studies so many others uh
can can receive the gospel. And just as
the spirit empowers the speaker, so too
can the spirit empower the interpreter.
Then in sec 1 Corinthians chapter 13:1,
it says, "Though I speak with the
tongues of men and of angels, but have
not love, I have become sounding brass
or a clanging symbol." Here Paul uses
hyperbole to describe how God's love
should penetrate and transform the
heart. We're not to conclude from this
passage that believers may speak a
literal language of angels. Just as we
are not to conclude that anyone can
possess all mysteries or all knowledge
in an absolute sense. Paul is saying
that even if one could attain the
highest imaginable spiritual experiences
or abilities, without godly love, these
gifts would be empty and meaningless.
Now, with everything that we've said so
far, here's where your roommate's
perspective on the gift of tongues be
comes into focus. 1 Corinthians 14:es
1:2. It says, "Pursue love and desire
spiritual gifts, but especially that you
may prophesy, for he who speaks in a
tongue does not speak to men, but to
God, for no one understands him, however
in the spirit he speaks mysteries." So
these verses imply that prophesying is
more profitable to our hearts than
speaking in a language that can that um
one cannot understand. Imagine if a
person preached an entire sermon with
power but did so in Mandarin or Arabic.
It would be no blessing. And so Paul
here is saying that it is better if one
prophesies where people can understand
but not speak in an unknown tongue which
is a known human language where the the
um those who hear him are not able to
have a translator to uh understand what
is being said. And so the gift of
tongues clearly is talking about human
languages that someone is able to
interpret across the world.
>> Amen. Amen. I think you answered that
very clearly too. So thank you. Sure.
>> All right. Uh, last question, Pastor
Denzy. This is uh, we don't know who it
came from, but it says, "Can or ask the
question, can angels still sin in
heaven? Why or why not?" [snorts]
Why or why not? That's a very good
question and one that we can understand
because God is love. God is love. And if
God is love, he's not going to make
robots to do whatever he wants. You
know, us humans, we want some robots to
do what the things we want them to do.
But God is not that way. He is love and
he has given all his creatures freedom
of choice. Freedom of choice. So yes,
they can send, but they choose not to.
The angels can send, but they choose not
to. Why? Because they love the Lord with
all their hearts, with all their soul,
all their mind. And uh as it says in
Psalms 103:20,
it says, "Bless the Lord, ye his angels
that excel in strength, that do his
commandments, hearkening unto the voice
of his word." Why? Because they love the
Lord. That's why they do that. Uh and
so, uh how about this one? Um the angels
delight in the Lord. Psalm 37:4,
"Delight thyself also in the Lord, and
he shall give thee the desires of thine
heart." They delight in loving the Lord,
serving the Lord with all of their
hearts. That's why they do not sin. And
so it says in Matthew 6:10, "Thy kingdom
come, thy will be done in earth as it is
in heaven." This is a choice. They can
do the will of God or they can choose
not to do the will of God. So they can
sin, but they choose not to. Why? Psalms
34:8. Because they have tasted and seen
that the Lord is good and they don't
want to be away from him. So praise the
Lord for that. I have to cut it short
there. [laughter]
That was very well answered in a very
short amount of time. So, praise God for
that. And uh I know that many of you had
your questions answered. So, we're just
going to go ahead. We're going to take a
quick break, show you how you can
continue to send in those questions, and
we'll be right back with some closing
thoughts.
If [music] you're enjoying our 3ABN
Bible Q&A, then tell your friends. Each
Monday, we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions [music]
you send us using God's holy word to
shed light on those texts that seem
difficult to understand. To have your
questions answered on a future [music]
program, just email them to us at
bibleqa3abn.tv.
[music]
That's bible qa3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
6182283975.
That's 618-228-3975.
Be sure to include your name and where
you live and then watch 3ABN Bible Q&A
for answers from God's word.
>> All right, welcome back to 3ABN Today
Bible Q&A. We just have a few short
moments for some closing comments. So,
Derell, I'll start with you.
>> Sure. I just want to bring some clarity
to the uh to Exodus 21 and the topic of
slavery. uh when God set God slavery
that existed back then, he wasn't
talking about what we see uh in uh more
modern centuries, the mid-Atlantic slave
trade and and other like forms of
slavery. He was talking about a form of
slavery where or servitude where the
person um often would willingly give
themselves to a person in order to pay
off a debt as I said um before. And so
we cannot compare that form of slavery
to what we saw where people were taken
against their will and taken from their
homes as we saw in the mid mid-Atlantic
slave trade.
>> Amen. Amen. Pastor Dindy,
>> I I would like to encourage people to
keep studying God's word, asking for the
Holy Spirit to help you understand. And
so finally, I'd like to say Psalm 34:8.
Oh, taste and see that the Lord is good.
I encourage you to taste and see that
the Lord is good. search for him with
all of your heart and you will be
rejoicing all the time.
>> Amen. Amen. I really enjoy Thank you uh
both of you for taking the time. Um and
I know like I said in the beginning of
this program that you were in prayer uh
asking for God to help you guide and
lead in you answering these questions.
And the one thing that kind of stuck out
to me uh Pastor Denzy was the one
question that you answered about the uh
the demoniac. And I think it's important
that we all remember this was a
gentleman who was possessed anywhere
between 4,000 and 6,000 demons and Jesus
freed him. And yet sometimes we wonder,
you know, God, can you ever help me
overcome this sin? Jesus, can you ever
help me? You know, he could do that for
the demoniac. He could do that for you.
So continue to send in your questions.
We will answer them here and go to the
Lord in [music] prayer. God bless you
and have a good day.
Heat. Heat.
>> [music]